[Music]
you know snake eyes as a voiceless
masked ninja now get ready to see a
whole new side of him
i didn't sign up for this
faced
and very bad at ninja stuff
what are you doing here
but did you know he was also a dick
stop sucker punching women in the face
snake eyes i'm trying to like you
stop
fast and furious presents gi joe begins
snake eyes origins from the book of saul
don't care about the gi joe movies
you're not alone no one does not even
the actors detail
but when the studio who placed last at
the box office for seven years straight
is calling the shots audiences will get
a brand new thing to shrug at because
after two prequels setting up a big joe
versus cobra showdown paramount is
rolling the dice with another prequel i
swear this whole studio is dangling by a
tom cruise fingertip
in a franchise known for its huge cast
of high-tech super soldiers focus on one
goon trying to [ __ ] his way through
ninja school but in the grand tradition
of solo the phantom menace and wolverine
origins learn how the character you love
used to suck back in the day he's a liar
he worked
you earned his trust he's a thief i was
hoping you wouldn't do that he's a
traitor to the people who welcomed him
his family we could have been brothers
he's kind of slow
and if he ever does join the gi joes
it's only because his dad used to work
there your father was one of us
he was a joe
knowing the right people is half the
battle
[Music]
follow snake eyes a man is lost and
wandering as his american accent
i've been a ghost for so long my
father's murdered when i was a kid he
must infiltrate the secretive arashika
ninja clan so secretive even they don't
know what they actually do a little of
this
they're led by tommy a man with every
reason to distrust this complete
stranger with no past but when you have
a face like henry golding doors just
seem to slide open to you even the doors
to the lantern warehouse where you hide
your magic ninja egg must resist his
charming face dude is
a dick
before they can make things a rashikagi
official snake eyes will have to pass
three deadly ninja tests test one
ask nicely for a bowl request that you
accept my ball in exchange for yours
test two
have a bad dream this is more than a
test you pass or fail it is a mirror to
reveal your weakness and test three do
not fight a giant snake i repeat do not
fight the snake if you want to pass they
never harm those who are pure of heart
which means you can graduate from this
ninja academy without doing any martial
arts see this is why you just can't find
a good ninja these days place is a total
mcdojo i heard they hand out orange
belts just for signing up
thrill had a cast of actors who are so
badass you could just show a wide shot
of them fighting and it would be brad to
watch featuring andrew koji a man who
crushed a role bruce lee wrote for
himself
eco-ooze an inhumanly fast physical
talent
the fight coordinator for some of
japan's best modern samurai films and
hand all these action figures over to
the legendary martial arts director
robert schwenke who's robert schwenke
let's see a couple of divergent movies
red r.i.p.d
uh-oh right well in that case abandon
all hope because no matter how good
these people may be in other films
they'll get the nauseating shaky cam
treatment usually reserved for liam
neeson hopping offense
[Music]
shaking the camera to make action more
exciting is like shaking a book to make
the words more exciting you want shaky
cam shake your head in front of the
screen
so now that you definitely don't have to
brave an actual theater to see it get
ready to hang the group chat while half
watching the latest hollywood prequel
that cares as little as possible about
gi joes and cobra as you legally can
when gi joe is on the poster he's your
head is with the jaws
what
they're the good guys oh well i guess
they can do better with snake eyes too
ninjitsu boogaloo there's still so many
gi joe ninjas to pick from let's see you
got dojo bonsai ah nunchuck
okay wait maybe the bad guys were cooler
that's either slice
and uh
dice
yeah let's just not do this actually
starring
snake snake snack
tommy kickles
ross altool wanna know how i got my scar
grand monster
hard masturbating
it was miss scarlet in the airport with
the stick things the aristocrats
my anacondas don't want none if you got
pure heart son
and
battles without honor and or clarity
if you want a real movie about ninja's
fighting cobra watch cobra vs ninja he
will not accept your challenge
he will
he can't refuse me when he receives the
ninja challenge card
then you've got to defeat me first
sure
[Music]
it's on youtube you're welcome
have you ever wanted to whoop
spider-man's ass we asked a martial arts
expert how they'd approach hand-to-hand
combat with some of earth's mightiest
heroes i mean you still definitely get
wrecked but it's nice to dream sometimes
you come at the king you best not miss
what is that an honest trailer says who
screen junkies
no
my son is also named bort
if it's too loud you're too old